we just can't wait to be king Oh
actually we can't wait for the Lion King
remake to be released seriously though
we have a feeling it's going to be a
good one
have you been wondering who will be
voicing all of your favorite characters
in the 2019 new movie keep watching to
find out who is behind the mice of The
Lion King Donald Glover first up is the
star of the show and everyone's favorite
lion Simba is going to be voiced by none
other than the extremely talented Donald
Glover Donald is more than just an actor
he is a writer musician comedian
producer and director
whoa that's a lot of roles he might have
heard him under one of his stage names
he goes by childish gambino dog got his
start as a writer on the sitcom 30 rock
then he got a role on the hit show
community which launched him into acting
Fame you're Doogie Seacrest I think I'm
better than everyone else because I'm 40
he currently is working as the creator
writer producer and star of the TV show
Atlanta this show is epic he won an Emmy
for outstanding actor in a Comedy Series
for his role back in 2017
you might also recognize him from
spider-man homecoming he also stole our
hearts as the young Lando Calrissian
from the Star Wars movie solo he's done
several stand-up comedy routines
he's also released several rap albums
under the name childish gambino and they
are amazing in 2018 he was nominated for
five Grammy Awards he won Best
traditional R&B performance Donald
Glover is one impressive guy and Time
magazine agreed in 2017 he was named one
of times 100 most influential people
everything you've heard about me this
truth we can't wait to see how awesome
he is as Simba
Seth Rogan Pumbaa is one of the funniest
Disney characters ever it makes sense
that one of the funniest comedy actors
will voice him and can you imagine
anyone more perfect for the role than
Seth Rogen he's got one of the most
recognizable faces in Hollywood and
surely the most recognizable laughs
gotta start acting way back in 1999 he
played Ken Miller on the teen sitcom
freaks and geeks he had several roles in
the next few years but he really rose to
fame when he starred opposite Katherine
Heigl in the 2007 film knocked up Steph
is best known for his really offensive
and inappropriate comedy most of his
films are definitely not family-friendly
Seth doesn't just star in his films he's
also a screenwriter
he has worked a lot with director Judd
Apatow on films like Superbad and
pineapple express he also acts with his
good friend James Franco they starred in
2014's the interview which was all about
a journalist to go into North Korea it
was a revelant and hilarious and it was
really controversial Seth isn't afraid
to make his audience uncomfortable for
the sake of comedy but he doesn't just
do adult comedy films he has done a lot
of voice acting before including Horton
gears of Hugh we just know he's going to
be a perfect Kumba Billy Eichner Pumas
BFF is just as funny of a character
Timon the meerkat is responsible for
introducing Simba to the philosophy of
Hakuna Matata so who is playing this
very important role in the new Lion King
that honor belongs to Billy Eichner
who's that you ask well you might be
more familiar with his voice than his
face Billy Eichner does a lot of voice
acting he's played chef pig in the Angry
Birds movie he played mr. Ambrose on
several episodes of Bob's Burgers
biographies under E thanks that's my job
and I love it he had a reoccurring role
in Parks and Recreation as craig
middlebrooks if you're into scary shows
you might recognize him as mutt nutter
on American Horror Story creepy Billy
was also a longtime performer with The
Upright Citizens Brigade that is a
comedy improv troupe that has given many
famous stars their start that includes
stars like Amy Poehler and Aziz Ansari
Billy Eichner isn't the only UCB alum in
Lion King Donald Glover was a member too
we're excited to hear Eichner Linda's
voice to the iconic meerkat you had
failed me for the last time James Earl
Jones most of the cast in the new Lion
King are brand new to their roles but
when you're as big of a legend as James
Earl Jones you get to reprise her role
as the original king of the Lions James
Earl Jones was the original Mufasa way
back in 1994 serabian I didn't see you
at the presentation of Simba and he's
back to voice Simba's father in 2019 we
are so excited James Earl Jones is a
Hollywood icon he has been acting since
the 1950s Wow where else have you heard
his famous voice Star Wars of course
James Earl has been the voice of Darth
Vader since the very first film he
reprised this role in rogue one in 2016
one of James Earls earliest films that
made him famous was the cult classic dr.
Strangelove from director Stanley
Kubrick James Earl is an amazing actor
and there is proof he is one of the only
fourteen people to be an eg OT what's
that you ask
it means he has won an Emmy a Grammy an
Oscar and a Tony pretty cool right James
Earl has starred in the 1995 movie pride
the Beloved Country which is based on
the classic novel about race in South
Africa but even though James Earl has
one of the most recognizable voices in
Hollywood he overcame a lot James Earl
told ABC News how he overcame a stutter
oh yeah
and young gettin through it without
stuttering
he has slowed down his acting in recent
years but you can often find him at
comic conventions where Star Wars fans
can get his autograph it's so cool that
he gets to play Mufasa again she would
tell at go4 up next is the evil brother
of Mufasa scar is the villain in the
Lion King but the actor who plays him is
far from a bad guy Chiwetel Ejiofor is
an awesome actor and all-around a great
person Chui Attalla starred in some
fantastic movies you might recognize him
from the intense drama 12 years a slave
I'm not falling to despair in this 2013
movie he played Solomon Northup a free
black northerner who is kidnapped and
sold into slavery
Chiwetel received a lot of praise for
his heart-wrenching performance he also
had a role in the iconic film Amistad
in fact his role as in sine Covey was
only his second acting credits he
doesn't always play really serious
historical roles he played Peter in Love
Actually
he also played Mordo in dr. strange this
is the star of The Living Tribunal the
British actor also enjoys stage acting
he is played Othello alongside Ewan
McGregor
he also starred as Romeo in a production
of Shakespeare's Romeo and Juliet he's
won several stage awards Ejiofor is also
a philanthropist and activist he has
done some amazing charity in Nigeria The
Lion King isn't the only film that to
a'tall will be in this year he's
directing and starring in the boy who
harnessed the wind it is about a young
boy who saves his village in Africa by
reading about and building a windmill
this will be his first directorial role
which he talks about in the Sundance
interview I think I've always been
kicking around with the idea of writing
something directing something we are so
excited to see him as scar Beyonce this
next actress needs no introduction none
other than the queen bee is playing Nala
Simba's love interest and we think
Beyonce Knowles is perfect for the role
Nala is a fierce independent character
it makes sense that Sasha Fierce would
voice her in the new movie
she tells 60 minutes Australia where the
fierce alter ego came from I named her
Sasha actually my cousin named her Sasha
Beyonce is best known for her music
career she got her start as the lead
singer of Destiny's Child back in the
90s she broke off from the band and
began an incredibly successful solo
career her most famous song is single
ladies for which she was nominated for a
Video Music Award but Beyonce is no
stranger to acting she starred in
Dreamgirls alongside Jennifer Hudson
back in 2006 she also acted in the
remake of pink hair there at the same
year
it was falling apart so I had it studied
with diamonds to wear on stage at the
presidential ball the Lion King will not
be the first time that Beyonce has
voiced an animated character either she
played Queen Tara in the film epic this
was about a girl who gets shrunk and
learns there's a whole kingdom of tiny
creatures living in her backyard she has
won several Grammy Awards and she has
been voted one of People Magazine's Most
Beautiful People beyonce is married to
rapper jay-z and they have three
children she is still one of the most
successful female artists of all time we
can't wait to hear her voice is our
favorite lioness John Connie next up we
have the voice of Rafiki
Rafiki is the eccentric monkey and
shaman who advises Mufasa he's the one
who holds up Simba as a baby to all the
animals of the plane Rafiki is going to
be played by the iconic Jon Connie
you probably recognize Jon from his role
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
he plays tataka the king of Wakanda and
father of two chala in the Captain
America Civil War he also makes an
appearance in a flashback during Black
Panther the South African actor has
played some amazing roles I'm grateful
to the Avengers for supporting this
initiative John has been acting since
1974 and he's got a really extensive
filmography he also has done plenty of
stage acting in the 70s he won a Tony
Award for his Broadway performance in
seas way Bungie is dead and the island
John has also done some Shakespearean
acting he was in the 2011 film
Coriolanus which was directed by Ralph
Fiennes John can act in pretty much any
type of role it takes a talented guy to
be able to play a Shakespeare role and a
super hero we bet he will be an awesome
Rafiki alfre woodard we know who is
playing Simba's dad but who is playing
his mom Surabhi
the role belongs to the lovely alfre
woodard even if you don't know her name
we bet you recognise her face off rejas
been acting for decades she had her
first role back in the 1970s so where
have you seen her recently she has
played Mariah Dillard on Marvel's Luke
Cage
I don't that's the truth that isn't her
first experience with Marvel she had a
small role in Captain America Civil War
and while she may not have been in the
recent movie Black Panther she's no
stranger to Vacanti in 2010 there was an
animated miniseries about the African
superhero
Alfre voiced the Queen Mother and
several other characters I have lived
plenty son I would die fighting
Alfre has done a lot of TV acting she
played Ruby Jean Reynolds the mother of
Lafayette on True Blood she also played
the president on state of affairs in
2014 and 2015
she has guest-starred on Empire a few
times too like her Lion King co-star
Beyonce she's been named one of People
Magazine's Most Beautiful People she has
several films coming out in 2019 we are
excited that she is joining other
awesome actors in the Lion King John
Oliver one of the funniest characters in
the original Lion King is Zazu this
hornbill bird is Mufasa is closest
advisor he's sarcastic and no-nonsense
and he is very frustrated by Simba we
were excited to learn that John Oliver
is voicing Zazu in the remake he has the
perfect voice for the grumpy bird which
you can see in his latest trailer for
last week tonight possibly the largest
raisin bran flakes in the world jon is
best known as a comedian and a
late-night host he got his start on The
Daily Show and The Colbert Report before
getting his own show last week tonight
with John Oliver started in 2014 but
even though he usually appears on TV as
himself he's no stranger to acting he
guest-starred on several episodes of
community he also voiced the role of
vanity Smurf in the 2011 Smurfs movie as
well as its sequel John is also a
successful writer he wrote for nearly
1,000 episodes of The Daily Show he has
an extensive history with stand-up
comedy too
number one John Oliver is not funny
oh poor John we think you're funny he
brings humor to serious issues like
politics he attributes to success too
after Ricky Gervais sees who recommended
the comedian to John Stewart Stewart was
the longtime host of The Daily Show
without that role John would not have
been nearly as successful as he is today
we can't wait to see him bring his quick
wit and biting sarcasm to Zazu it's
going to be epic
JD McCreary okay we know that Donald
Glover is playing Simba but he is only
playing the adult Simba in the original
movie a child actor played the voice of
young Simba but that child actor
Jonathan Taylor Thomas is all grown up
so who is playing the new young Simba
it looks like JD McCreary is the cub who
just can't wait to be king you might
have seen him perform at the Grammys
with Donald Glover his Lion King co-star
he talks all about his career in an
interview with Kate I is FM then they
said um do you want to perform at the
Grammys with Donald Glover and of course
we said yes it's the Grammys come on JD
has been acting since 2014 he has
several small roles including a Disney
Channel guest appearance
he played young Ernie on kc undercover
it was just a really big moment for me
because I that like you have to start
somewhere he had a few other guest
appearances on TV shows one of those was
an episode of teachers in 2018 he got a
role on the panes he played Kenny Payne
well I'm busy so go on and do and the
kid can sing on a 20-19 episode of
American souls he played a young Michael
Jackson he is also in another movie that
is releasing later this year called
little he's definitely off to a great
start
we just know we are going to keep seeing
great things from JD as he gets older
shall hadi right Joseph last but
certainly not least is the actress who
plays young Nala this actress is pretty
new to Hollywood but she is going places
jihadi right Joseph only has four acting
credits to her name right now her first
role was on hairspray live this was a
live TV version of the famous musical
Hairspray she said it was the most fun
ever in an interview with black
Hollywood live I had the best time of my
life it was so exciting and so much fun
everybody there was so sweet and so nice
it looks like fun the story deals with
an overweight girl in the sixties who
wants to be on a local TV show it also
deals with some serious race issues
specifically discrimination in
television Shahani plays little one as
the little sister of one of the main
characters and this girl has an amazing
voice she told Alexis toy VIP access
that she loved the choreography too I
especially love all of the choreography
and the music and the cast was so sweet
shadi has three more movies coming out
soon which he hints at in the black
hollywood live interview well there's
some things on the line that I might be
moving to LA for us will be released in
2019
just like Lion King and she is currently
filming a movie called dreamers we are
so pumped to hear her voice in the new
Lion King movie we have a feeling we'll
be seen a lot more from Shahaji right
Joseph over the next several years
that's it for the actors behind the mic
of Disney's The Lion King remake thanks
for watching be sure to subscribe to the
things for more awesome behind the
scenes videos
[Music]